this is a production of Cornell
University
my research is about change processes
and opportunities for property of
participation in eastern India and I'm
excited for this opportunity to share
with all of you a little bit about the
work that I've done so far on this topic
and my plans for future research
so diversification is a Hot Topic
globally you can see from the scrap that
the number of Journal articles published
with the term diversification has
increased drastically over the last
couple of decades and the interest in
crop diversification really stems from
its potential to address several of the
most depressing problems we have stage
and those are
first improving ergonomic and
environmental outcomes
then improving Farmers incomes thereby
reducing poverty and finally improving
nutritional stability
there's also a lot of interest in crop
diversification in India
um with reference to a lot of the same
potential outcomes
welfare nutritional outcomes improving
resilience to climate shocks and even
reducing carbon footprint it's too much
but even though everyone is researching
projects under this Banner sorry a prop
diversification the definitions of
proper diversification vary pretty
drastically from diversifying the
profits
to replacing current crops with new
crops and this latter definition is
especially common in Indian literature
and in the Indian development literature
also and typically refers to replacing
crabs with high value costs
so these very varied understandings of
prop diversity make it difficult to
describe functional value to
diversification which brings me to the
initial question driving
what types of diversification make sense
for what types of farmers in what
contexts
and with what outcomes
so so far I've been exploring these
questions in the context of pikar which
is a state in eastern India in the end
of a diet Plains
and I argue that this is a good a good
location for me to continue this
research for several reasons one we are
saving several problems that crop
diversification may help to address
there's extremely high rates of poverty
and malnutrition in the heart and
there's also frequency of droughts and
floods
um
there's also potential for a high impact
of crop diversification as an abdomen
for improving development outcomes in VR
because there's a large portion of the
population that depends on agriculture
for their buttons and there's also the
cropping system is mainly rice and wheat
so there's a lot of opportunity for
diversifying to different crops
but there's also opportunity for
researching thick crucification there
because of pockets and fibrancy and also
changes over time that are interesting
to look at
there's also interest amongst government
and field community in Bihar and last
but not least we have research
connections
which is the
um serial systems Initiative for South
Asia is a program that Andy has been
involved with for many years and they're
based in Bihar so we have some strong
research support there
foreign
was to start bringing into
why the spatial diversity what can
explain spatial diversity
um between farms in the car
and so to do this I used the national
sample survey from 2012-2013 which
surveyed 35 000 Farmers across all of
India and it went to each of these
households twice once in the OR monsoon
season and once in the Ravi or dry skin
and I focused for this analysis on the
Ravi season because there's more
diversification
um in the Robbies we've been compared to
the academy season in deep Harbor
and the measure that I used for
diversity with the Simpson diversity
index which measures both the number of
crops and how evenly area is distributed
between crops
and it's an index on a scale of zero to
one so zero is no diversity there's only
one crop grown and as it approaches one
the diversity and increasing
um and looking at the data from this
National sample survey in Behar
um a lot of the farmers are just growing
one prop in the Robbie season
anyways I don't know oh there
um
and
so because of that distribution I
decided to split my analysis into a
logistic regression and a linear
regression first looking at
um why are some Farmers collecting more
than one crop and then looking at of
those farmers who are blending more than
one crop what is their diversity index
and I had some interesting findings
first I found that larger Farm size is
associated with growing more than one
Robbie crop but not with greater
diversity indices
second I found that growing more than
one crop and higher diversity indices
are both associated with growing the
higher value props or non-serials
third I found that
households are more dependent on
agriculture tend to grow more than one
product
in addition to this I looked at several
other factors at the household level
which I've listed at the bottom of the
slide here which didn't turn out to be
significant in this analysis
but importantly there are also factors
above the household level which were
significant including a village effect
so households that are in a village
where other farmers are more diverse
also tend to be more diverse themselves
the second piece of preliminary work I'd
like to tell you about today is uh
comes from Key informant interviews that
I conducted in Bihar this past summer
and I'm not going to walk through each
of these Maps but I just wanted to show
you that I created all these maps of
diversity patterns and Trends last
spring and I used them to guide
conversations with people
so just to give you one example of how
those conversations went on the left
here are maps that I made with the
national sample survey household level
data and it's household level
um diversity
averaged at the district level
and so the top one yeah it's 2018 data
and the bottom one is the change from
2012 to 2018
diversity
and then I've outlined in red where the
patterns that I saw in magnets did not
match what I learned from my key
performance and then I have outline in
yellow where the the what I was learning
from performance did kind of make sense
with the maps that I made
and
so with these maps and as well as with
other maps of castle level diversity and
District level diversity that I
discussed with key informants
um sometimes match and sometimes don't
um but what the conversation always kept
coming back to was what crops are Behind
These patterns and these trends and so I
came away feeling like diversity index
may not be the best way of understanding
cropping system distributions and
changes in being hard maybe looking at
the actual crops is is more relevant
the final piece of preliminary work that
I'd like to share with you is um comes
from focus group discussion that I had
with farmers in Bihar uh digging into
trying to understand their decision
making about their cropping systems so
this slide summarizes
um focus groups that I had in big piece
that I which is a district in central
Bihar
and um just for an example looking at
the karish season
10 10 or so years ago farmers were
transitioning from rice and Maize to
soybean and the reasons they gave for
that brain was decreasing soybean is
more tolerant to Drought soybean is
bringing more profits
um they had to invest Less in fertilizer
for they weren't fertilizing soybeans so
they were getting more profit than with
these and they also mentioned the
processing being easier with soybean
compared to me
and then coming to some more current
trends
um
Paul armyworm is a new pest that they're
dealing with in porn so there's they're
shifting what area they have left and
born more towards soybean now and then
they talked about electric irrigation as
something that is planned to come into
their area and they said that if
electric irrigation does come then they
would be interested in switching from
soybean back to price actually because
it's a more assured problem
so some take-home points from this
preliminary work first from the
regression analysis
um that factors that multiple scales are
influencing diversity at the farm level
so land size and Market orientation and
Lively infrastructure are important at
the household level but there's also
factors above the household level that
you have to fit into account for any
analysis
and then from Key informant interviews I
learned that maps of diversity index are
not particularly useful without
information about the specific crops
that are behind those patterns and those
trends
and then from armor interviews I learned
that farmers are not thinking in terms
of diversification they're just thinking
in terms of what crops to grow this year
given the current constraints and
opportunities
and the major factors influencing their
decisions are irrigation pests labor and
profit
so now getting into my proposal for my
dissertation research
but I would like my usage to be able to
do is to inform development programming
that promotes crop diversification that
fits the local context
and and being purposely based here and
using the term diversification
um allowing it to Encompass different
transitions for different contexts
and so the way I see it the problem is
that in the literature this focus on
concepts of diversity and
diversification are too messy for
understanding change processes decision
processes and outcomes so my proposed
solution if they cannot research that
really gets that how and why copying
patterns are changing
how partners are making decisions about
cropping systems and where changing the
copy pattern can result in improved
ergonomic outcomes
so following that I'll read you my
research questions the first is how have
cropping patterns in V heart changed
over time and what were the regional
scale drivers of those changes
the second
what types of cropping patterns are
farmers following what factors at the
household level and Beyond are
associated with those different patterns
what are the outcomes and how do farmers
decide which pattern to follow
and finally when and where can
diversification out of cuddle rights
improve the water use efficiency of heat
so I'm going to talk through each of
these questions a little more and along
with my planned methods
so for the first question how have
cropping patterns of the card change
over time and what were the region scale
drivers for those changes my first
action item is to create maps of
District level crop areas and I'll do
that using Department of Agriculture
data and you can see
they'll look something like what I
already have here on the right
um
second the second point is to identify
large-scale Trends either by visually
comparing the maps for example you can
see some Trends here
um so the
wheat is the dark blue the light blue is
amazed if you focus on the maze in the
in the Northeast region of Bihar
um comparing the two years you can see
that the area underneath increased
um so some Trends can be seen visually
but in order to create a more formalized
groupings and cropping system Trends I
will use canines or late in class
analysis to create clusters based on
propagation trends
um
then I will show these maps and clusters
to key Employments so people from
government ngos Market aggregators Etc
and hope about the drivers behind these
trends and finally I will conduct case
studies looking at Maze and pulses so
um as I mentioned the maze area has
increased in the Northeast and this will
provide an interesting example of a case
where a market crop has really come in
to a region in a big way
then I'll look at the pulse story which
is a little more complicated so if you
look at the southwest corner here and
you again wheat is the dark blue but
basically everything that starts not
dark blue here or pulses and you can see
that they've decreased in this time
period but they're still there they're
still persistent and so
um this is another interesting story to
look into because pulses are an
important crop for nutrition and soil
health and are also valued highly by the
government so it's another change
process that I excellent
my second question what types of
cropping patterns are farmers following
what factors at the household level and
Beyond influence those patterns what are
the outcomes and how do farmers make
decisions about what patterns follow
so first I'm going to use the data from
the NSS to create clusters of households
with similar properties
so on the right is a map that shows the
great variety of cropping patterns that
exist
um and behind you can see the the blue
is right sweet I I don't expect you to
be able to read this but I just wanted
you to see that there's a great
diversity of different cropping patterns
followed
um but I will need to again use that
clustering approach to reduce these
cropping systems into a manageable
number of groups that I can analyze and
once I have those groups then I'll
conduct a multivariate logistic
regression with cluster as the outcome
and looking at various household Village
and District level predictor variables
and so that will include things like I
saw where important like land size and
Market orientation
irrigation and then going zooming out
and looking at Agro logical climactic
factors
um like drainage and drain Call Etc
and then I'll run some regressions to
look at outcomes using the data from the
NSS there are a few outcomes we can look
at when it's income we can also look at
the share of produce that was sold at a
satisfaction price consumer expenditure
and financial assets
and finally I'll conduct a case study in
a district where there's a lot of
variation for example I'm thinking they
can survive the Central District there's
a lot of variation cropping systems
there
um and so this case study will seek to
understand why farmers are in a district
where it is fairly possible to follow
these different cropping systems how our
Farmers deciding you can use systems
and so finally my last question
um
how much can diversification improve
economic resilience to climate change
specifically when and where can
diversification out of cuddle rice
improve the water usage of wheat
so irrigation is common in Bihar
um but it's still the main limiting
factor to yield and this is because of
irrigation relies on energy that's
expensive and polluting and it's
becoming even more of a limited factor
with terminal heat stress that is more
of a more of a problem with wheat in
recent years
so there's interest in better managing
green water products
and one solution could be
re-establishing natural Capital like
soil physical quality by diversifying
out of puddle threats which we know is
very destructive to soil structure
so
um
but how much can diversifying out of
petal rights improve the water use
efficiency of the subsequently crop and
how does That Vary depending on soil
type wheat planting time Etc But to
answer these questions I plan to conduct
some on-farm experiments I'll select
Farms with puddled rice direct seeded
rice and Maize and stratified by soil
pipe or drainage class and wheat
planting time then we'll apply some
irrigation treatments the outcome of
interest will be wheat broke per unit
water and will also measure soil
hardness and temperature and maturity as
those will influence the outcome that
we're interested in and
yeah and then finally I'm going to the
last to address the last part of this
question it'll be a modeling exercise
probably working with modeling software
like appsum
um and I'll use the results from the
on-parm experiments to create a model
that predicts where diversification Auto
rights will improve the water use
efficiency and climate resilience of
with that I'd like to thank you all for
your attention
thank you to all these people for
helping me produce information
do you have any questions
yeah I think it's really cool here
um uh I had a question about the models
um when you have all the survey data and
you're looking for predictors are you
basing the ones you choose on like
interviews and personal or like
knowledge or like starting with all
those variables and doing some sort of
model so much
um so I'm cut yeah so I'm kind of I'm
limited by the variables that exist in
the NSS data so I'm kind of taking the
the instead of doing qualitative first
and using that to inform the
quantitative part of my research and
creating the opposite this way so I'm
doing quantitative analysis of the data
and then using the results from that to
inform my qualitative research and
interviews that I'll be designing like
I'll be designing interview guides in
January again February
thank you
yeah so if part of what would help or
make it more diverse is is you could
move a little bit away from wheat wheat
with like yeah and they're with what's
happening in Ukraine that's where they
grow a lot of wheat so then we prices go
up
like like the timing of when you had
done the surveys and the models already
is that built in already or can you
factor that in that there's this budget
potential for diversification if wheat
prices accident if it goes up to wide
we're sort of
stuff
um
that's a good question
um
so the question is about wheat prices
yeah just and I maybe you're not even
going to try to project like what's the
potential for diversification but if you
are it seems like the things like that
and you can't predicted how long the war
is going to go on
right yeah
um
you'll have to come come back
sorry maybe it's Way Beyond the scope
oh yeah
any other questions for cure I think
we're at times oh just a quick question
I noticed in one of your early slides
that elevation was an important factor
across the bridge can you say a little
bit about that why would that be were
you surprised
especially since
um like the heart is pretty flat it
doesn't vary a whole lot in elevation
but
um so we think but I think it might be
epoxy for something else like drainage
is really the main thing that's driving
thanks a lot
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu